[موسيقى]
حدود السودان وإثيوبيا
هي المحطة الأخيرة في الرحلة إلى بر الأمان
في الأسابيع الأولى من الصراع ، حيث عبر
آلاف اللاجئين من منطقة Digde في إثيوبيا
يوميًا الآن الأرقام تتضاءل
يومًا بعد يوم ، أولئك الذين
يأتون إلى هنا ويحملون ندوبًا
وشهادات  هذه الزرايجا
يقول إنه هرب من مدينة شيرارو بالقرب
من منطقة إثيوبيا.
يقول إن الجنود الإريتريين ضربوهم بالمدافع الرشاشة
ووضعوها على الأرض ووضعوا الأسلحة
في أفواههم.
شجاع لقد هربت
بحياتك والندوب على ظهرك
هذا الشاب هو أيضًا من شاردو وقد
وصف نفس المشهد
لكنه طلب منا عدم مشاركة اسمه
مثل الكثيرين
هنا وما زال خائفًا من الصعب جدًا معرفة
ما يحدث في
منطقة إثيوبيا  نظرًا لأن الحكومة
فرضت تعتيمًا للاتصالات
، فقد أمضى فريق CNN على الحدود السودانية الإثيوبية
أيامًا في جمع شهادات من
اللاجئين الذين قالوا إنهم
استُهدفوا بسبب  وريث تيجراي الإثني يخوضون
مخاطر خطيرة للعثور على
الأمان
وصلت فيوري إلى السودان مع طفل حديث الولادة
حامل بشدة عندما هوجمت جوميرو من
قبل الجيش الإثيوبي
فرت فايوري من خلال الجذور الخلفية
للولادة في
حقل تخبرنا به هي
ووالدتها فقط  القانون جعلنا
لا نستطيع التحقق من رواياتهم بشكل مستقل ،
لكنهم جميعًا
يروون قصة مماثلة أن الجيش الإثيوبي
دخل البلدة التي يقولون إنهم يخبرون
المدنيين بأنهم آمنون
يغادرون الجنود
الإثيوبيين ثم وصلت مجموعات مسلحة أخرى
هربت من حميرة على مسافة قريبة من المدينة.
أطلق النار على الحدود السودانية لميليشيا وانو
وبدأ الناس
بالفرار ، وأصيب في ساقه برصاصة
وسقط على الأرض
اختلط جسده
بجثث أخرى متكدسة فوقه
وألقاه رجال الميليشيا في مجرى مائي.
تركه
ليموت ، وقال أحد أفراد الميليشيا العرقية المتحالفة
مع القوات الإثيوبية ،
إنه تم إنقاذه من قبل لاجئي تيغراي الآخرين
الذين عثروا عليه وساعدوه على
الفرار إلى السودان ،
أبراهام يبلغ من العمر 21 عامًا.  يقول أيضًا إنه
ترك ميتًا بسبب الضمادة ،
حيث أظهر لنا جرح الضمادة حيث
يقول إنه تعرض للهجوم
بفأس. ونفت متحدثة باسم
رئيس الوزراء الإثيوبي هذه المزاعم
وأخبرت CNN أن
شهادات هؤلاء اللاجئين هي نتيجة
الخوف من الآخر.  دعاية كانت
قيادة تيغراي قد
أطعمت شعبها على مدى
العقود الثلاثة الماضية ، ونفت المتحدثة
وجود ميليشيا واناو أمهرة
لكنها في الوقت نفسه
أقرت بشكل مربك
أن ميليشيا منطقة الأمهرة كانت
منخرطة إلى حد تأمين
المدن الحدودية بين المنطقتين.
بعد الإطاحة بالديكتاتور السابق
رامال بشير
وتدفق اللاجئين هذا لم يجد
الكثير من الراحة
على هذا الجانب من الحدود ولكنه على
الأقل مكان آمن في
لندن